I understand what you're saying I
understand what you're saying but the
idea the idea the idea that this is one
percent of men have created this
terrible Society yeah I talk about that
I talk about the Matrix I talk about
these things but it's always been this
way it's always been a small Elite group
of men who are in charge of the world
and unfortunately now we're fighting
battles in different ways the the days
of old a man proved his worth by going
to war basically every man at any point
in his life was going to end up going to
war and he came back Victorious he came
back with honor he got himself a wife
that's that's how it works right now men
don't have to go to war as much
depending on where you live in the world
and it's slightly different and we fight
our Wars in other ways and one of the
true expressions of testosterone and
trying to really express your ability
and your combative ability now in the in
the modern world is power and influence
so in the olden days you go to war you
come back with a ribbon nowadays you go
on x amount of followers you can move
the world with money